hallo freunde und herzlich willkommen zu
einem krankheitsrisiko dieser position
hatte mich wahrscheinlich noch nie
gesehen aber ich liege gerade bei mir im
bett weil ich bin krank bei der liebe
freunde ich bin richtig krank und das
meine ich jetzt nicht im verrückten
sinne sowie ihr das aus videos kennt
oder so sondern dann vielleicht hat man
schon meine stimme ist mir egal ich
schnappe mir den stock aus der nase und
ich muss mega viel husten und heute ist
gerade montag und ich muss eigentlich
videos vorproduziert das wochenende weil
ich wieder wohin muss aber das kriege
ich nicht wenn der grund dafür ist meine
lieben freunde ich bin so krank dass ich
euch schon das gesagt freunde hört mir
einfach nicht zu ich liege auf jeden
fall gerade im bett hier mit meinem
konto lee den linkshändern ihren den bis
steinbach jetzt kann ja mal so einen
scheiß deutsche team ebenfalls liege ich
jetzt hier gerade bei mir im bett und
ich dachte mir jetzt hier für montag
wenn ich voll produzieren muss sage ich
euch einfach freunde die letzten vier
fünf sechs videos bzw tage kamen
regelmäßig videos ok wann kommen endlich
mal nicht regelmäßig videos jedenfalls
bin ich halt einfach mega im arsch wenn
ihr mal schau dich drücken den ganzen
tag hier wasser ich nehme mir
irgendwelche ich nehme mir so die ganze
zeit solche husten tabletten und vitamin
c und war gerade sogar schon einkaufen
habe mir zitronen und orangen gekauft
und hat mit frisch gepressten saft immer
jedenfalls habe ich mir gedacht
natürlich könnte ich vermutet auch
minecraft video machen wo ich einfach
dann versuche gesund zu sein und
versuche vernünftig zu kommentieren und
irgendwas zu machen aber freundlich mit
ehrlichkeit euch ich bin einfach krank
und wenn man krank ist hat man keine
motivation zunächst ich lieg ich gerade
einfach bei mir im bett ihren und macht
nichts es tut mir leid an alle die jetzt
eventuell ein video erwartet hatten wo
ich irgendwie von der brücke springen
spaß so fühle ich mich auch gerade ich
habe durch die nase habe ich schmerzen
in den ganzen stier in meine ohren tun
weh ich bin so einfach wie das ganze
zeit
am husten und alles und ja ich weiß
nicht woran es liegt aber jeder wird mal
krank da hilft auch mein immunsystem wir
dann nicht beziehungsweise ich hoffe
dass ich wieder gesund werde und dann
war's das auch schon wird diesen rotax
video was ich jetzt einfach so ganz
spontan gemacht habe weil freund ich
wollte ja sagen ich bin krank deswegen
konnte bekam diese letzten tage nicht so
häufig videos beziehungsweise
unregelmäßig und das tut mir sehr leid
diese woche werde ich versuchen wieder
jeden tag zu machen was vernünftig ist
aber ich habe auch am wochenende viel
gemacht gearbeitet und so weiter und so
fort und freunde es gibt neuigkeiten
unter anderem mit max wird bald was
cooles koffer mit zwei anderen dann wird
bald von mir was cooles kommen und so
weiter also wir sind da krass was am
plan freunde das wird euch allen
gefallen wenn ihr ja hallo leo ich finde
einfach nur bei youtube ist es halt
wichtig dass ich jetzt nicht ein video
mache wo ich einfach nur krank wird und
versuche mich dann irgendwie weise die
ich versuche das coole zu kriegen weil
es hat man bei der board review letztes
gesehen wo ich euch die grossmatt
vorgestellt habe oder so weil ich halt
auch pilger kamen habe ich auch selber
im schnitt nachher gemerkt alte was ich
für eine klage also ich glaube halt
immer so ein bisschen schwach sind und
so aber das bin ich halt einfach und
dabei zeit echt da hab ich wirklich
gemerkt beim schnitt so junge du bist
krank könnt ihr bei der pause das heißt
es dass gerade 20 uhr ich werde jetzt
einfach wirklich schlafen gehen ich muss
mal wieder um acht uhr zur uni also halb
sieben aufstehen oder so aber dann
kriegt auf jeden fall mehr schlaf als in
die 56 stunden oder so da ist freute ich
habe jetzt auch nicht mehr dazu das
video sehe ich schon wieder ist hier
wieder fast fünf minuten lang im
nächsten tage kommt wieder häufiger
videos wir sehen uns in einem anderen
video wieder tolle szene
ich liebe euch freuen